to those of you in the northern
hemisphere where it's currently winter
I envy you it's about 30 degrees in the
office but the ray tracing series must
go on hey so guys my name is John and
welcome back to the New Year to the ray
tracing series we're gonna have a bit of
a chill episode today we're just going
to talk about some kind of performance
optimization things and more importantly
answering the question of how do I find
out what the bottleneck is how do I find
the Slow part so last episode we talked
about multi-threading what we did is we
took our currently running code and we
made it scale across all of the CPU
cores we have available to us
we did that using this kind of STD for
each function with the parallel
execution policy and we even have a
little Define here that lets us kind of
toggle that on and off and our
performance with that running with the
multi-threading was around like 26 or so
milliseconds per frame on my laptop
which for reference is running an AMD
ryzen 9 5900 HX CPU and you can see all
of the cores here being fully saturated
now it doesn't take a genius to see that
a performance of like 26 to like 30 or
so milliseconds
using that many threads and that many
cores versus if I just shut off
multi-threading versus about 60
milliseconds like
you know that's about twice as fast
maybe a little bit more than twice as
fast which doesn't really make sense
when you take a look at what this looks
like like the CPU is mostly idle so how
does throwing that much more Hardware at
it result in such a such an incremental
performance boost I mean it's not that
incremental twice as fast as still good
but it's definitely not like eight times
as fast which is something that I would
kind of expect what's interesting as
well is that if we actually take a look
at our code the part that we are
specifically interested in measuring the
performance for and what that timer
represents that's not just one frame of
our application if we actually take a
look at Walnut app dot CPP here you'll
see that that specific timer
last round of time which let's scroll up
over here that last render what that
actually represents is a timer that we
start at the beginning of the render
function and we then get its elapsed
milliseconds at the end of the render
function so these three functions are
really what we're measuring here now on
resize is doing nothing right because
there's no resize necessary so if
there's no resize necessary you can see
we have a very kind of early out over
here a very short path and over here as
well if nothing's changed we just return
so really it's just this function that
we're measuring and this function
consists of what exactly well I mean a
little memset maybe here some
assignments that doesn't really count
and then the big kind of meat of it is
this kind of for Loop and then we just
do set data which will upload those
pixels to the GPU and then we do some
other kind of housekeeping here so
really it's either this function or it's
the for Loop that's taking up most of
the time so then if it is the for Loop
and we do in fact compute it in parallel
now we should expect a rather large
increase in performance and if we don't
then there's probably something else
that's stopping us it's probably another
culprit and specifically with
multi-threading when you go and you take
something and you make it multi-threaded
and you don't see a huge increase in
performance you can be pretty sure
there's something inside that
multi-threaded code
might not be as straightforward and as
innocent as it seems and today what
we're going to do is we're going to
investigate we're going to be a bit of a
code detective if you will it's like I'm
making the series for children I need to
find my monocle now I'm going to show
you guys how we can investigate this a
little bit further and figure out what
exactly the slow part of this is but
first I want to thank brilliant for
sponsoring this video and this Ray
tracing series brilliant is an amazing
website filled with many many courses on
various stem topics they're a sponsor
that's actually really really useful for
what we're doing here if you want to
learn more about all of the math that
goes into Ray tracing brilliant are one
of the best places in the internet to do
so because they have a large number of
really high quality well-made math
courses that cover pretty much all of
the math that you need for Ray tracing
like for example their linear algebra
course or their calculus course these
are all things that you need to know and
whilst they can be rather complicated
topics brilliant does a really good job
at simplifying them and presenting them
in such an easy to follow way with all
these like widgets you can play with to
visualize how the mouth is actually
working they'll quiz you after each
lesson to make sure that you're actually
learning the content and they've
packaged up these classes into just
really bite-sized consumable chunks if
you just have 15 minutes at the end of
the day you can progress you can learn
another amazing thing is that you can
get started for free just go to
brilliant.org the channel link will be
in the description below and check it
out for yourself see if you like it and
if you do brilliant have been nice
enough to offer the first 200 of my
subscribers 20 off an annual membership
huge thank you as always to Brian for
sponsoring this video so now that we
have our detective hat on let's see what
we can do so one of the things with
optimization that's really really
important is you have to fundamentally
understand what what is going on if
you're not sure what your code is doing
exactly and that also applies to like
you know Distributing your code across
cores as well if you're not sure exactly
what your code is doing then this is
going to be much harder and possibly a
bit of a waste what I'm talking about is
if we just scroll down here so I can
draw we know all ultimately that Ray
tracing is kind of just a bunch of math
what we're really doing like if this
little box here is all of the kind of
code that has to run for one frame to
render a frame we know that most of it
is just kind of all of these
mathematical equations we also know that
these mathematical equations have to
like largely like most of them have to
be done per pixel that we're rendering
what that means is that if we have like
an image that's say like 1920 by 1080 we
know that that is about 2 million or so
pixels so we know that we have to go
through this math two million times now
again this might not be all of the math
like if we hit like you know if we don't
hit anything for example then we just
like go to that Miss function and we
just return the sky color that's pretty
easy and on the other side of the
spectrum if we actually hit like say
this sphere and then we bounce and we
hit this sphere and we go somewhere else
and obviously we have to do a little bit
more math because that kind of Bounce
rate is going to intersect with
something else which means we have to
run through that math again so the the
amount of math that we do per pixel
actually like will vary but the point is
when you have like math that needs to be
done many many times and it's not
dependent on each other that is a really
good kind of candidate for optimization
via multi-threading because since
there's no kind of dependency they just
all need to be done at the end of the
frame so that you can present your image
you can dispatch them across really any
number of threads and we kind of talked
about this in the last multi-threading
episode this is more of a recap but I
want to go too deep into that if you
haven't checked out that video though I
highly recommend you do it's also why we
can for example dispatch this on the GPU
and it's going to be much faster because
the GPU will have thousands of cores not
just like 8 or 16 or 32 or whatever and
this as you can see is a very good
candidate for parallelization now why am
I talking about this we've already done
it why am I talking about this because
it's important for us to understand
exactly what we've done if we know that
we have all this math to do and it's so
easily divisible into like so many cores
then we know that if the math itself is
the thing that is taking up the most
time and we suddenly go ahead and we
basically reduce that like let's just
say we decide for now we'll make four
threads right if the math takes as it
did about 60 milliseconds per frame and
we decide that you know what let's split
this up into four cores what does that
mean that means that each core is now
responsible for four times less math
because we've taken that entire like
mass of math that we have to do and
we've divided it across four different
Chords it's kind of like I don't know
maybe you're at a party and you need to
like I don't know put some plates down
the table there's like 100 guests and
you have to put 100 plates down if you
get three of your friends to help you
out then you can just give them 25
plates each and you'll each hand out 25
players you've reduced that kind of work
by four times you now have 25 plates to
place rather than 100 each of you have
25 and you could of course do that
simultaneously as long as you don't like
crash into each other so that's
basically the same thing as what we've
done here by enrolling like four cores
total instead of one we've gone ahead
and we've taken the 60 milliseconds
worth of math supposedly and we've kind
of divided it by four and 60 divided by
four of course is 15. so what we kind of
would expect is that each one of those
threads should take 15 milliseconds now
because they have a quarter of this work
that is 60 milliseconds and because
they're running concurrently at the same
time that total operation now should
take 15 milliseconds and not 60. now
what we are seeing is a lot more than
four cores we're throwing eight cores
and 16 kind of threads at it so if we
have eight cores we've thrown like you
know twice as much into this so again
you can probably take that 15 divided by
2 and you get about 7.5 milliseconds or
so and again technically even faster if
we take advantage of the other kind of
hyper threading situation that we have
so then when we see something that is
between 26 and 30 that should raise some
eyebrows and I'm kind of going through
this like the long way there's obviously
a much easier way like if this was a
speed run to get from like having this
problem to salute to solution I probably
wouldn't go down this much thought but
again I'm kind of using this as like a
bit of a teaching example just so that
you understand what's going going on and
why why these numbers don't look
reasonable now when you see something
like this
the first thing that I would think of is
that this is not as independent as it
looks so we know that theoretically this
math should not have any dependency on
the other math that's occurring what I
mean is like one pixel that we're
processing should not be dependent on
another pixel but
these numbers are telling me that there
might actually be some kind of a link
between them some kind of dependency
between them that's actually slowing
this down now the most like common thing
I can probably think of is restricting
access to a particular resource so
sometimes when you have something that
is needed by all of these cores
probably should have picked a different
color like red uh this kind of resource
will say that's needed by all of these
cores means that when one of these
instructions from these cores actually
requests this a number of different
things can happen such as for example a
lock and when a lock happens it means
that until this core has received its
answer and it's got its results it's got
whatever it needs from that resource
nothing else can continue everything
else has to wait because if they're all
kind of waiting on that resource and
then one of the cores has locked it then
that means that that's it everything
kind of stalls until it unlocks it and
then the next core kind of one at a time
can actually go there it's kind of like
if a bunch of people have to enter or
leave a stadium and there's just kind of
one doorway and you have to all get
checked by the security guard so it's
like single file you might have like so
many people that can obviously move
around the stadium at once and
everything's fast but as soon as they
have to get through that that doorway
they have to go single file and they get
checked one at a time it's kind of the
same thing I think my camera is about to
overheat we better hurry this up and I
hope it makes sense why I'm saying that
that's one of the most likely candidates
because again theoretically speaking if
we truly have a bunch of independent
math that needs to be done like CPUs
exist to do math right CPU cores they
can they each can do math there's no
restrictions there if you have data
flowing in and out and you have four of
those cores you do math four times
faster it's that simple because
everything you need to compute that
particular thing is contained like
within that core and it's happy to just
get to work what starts to become an
issue is when you have to communicate
say to and from memory and it's some
kind of like shared memory that may need
to be locked in some way and like the
the kind of access to it has to be you
know restricted but if you if you kind
of BYO data and you output to something
that is also not kind of potentially
locked for writing then that's it you
just flow through very quickly nothing
gets in your way so that being said
where could the culprit be now we could
go through all of this code you know and
try and work out what it is that we're
doing that is a little bit suspicious
but of course there's a much easier way
and that is why don't we just let like a
profiler do that for us because what a
profiler will do and specifically just
you know a normal sampling kind of
profiler we don't need like any
instrumentation or anything too deep
here but just a normal sampling profiler
what it will do is it will collect
samples throughout our entire
application and by samples what I mean
is it will more or less just ask the
program hey where are you currently
and it will do that a lot and obviously
if we're inside a function say per pixel
and we're spending a lot of time here if
I ask you uniformly over the course of
one second if I ask you 1 000 times
where you are and like ninety percent of
the time 900 times you tell me I'm
inside the per pixel function then I
know that out of that one second you
spend this much time in per pixel and if
I increase the number of times I ask you
so I increase the sampling frequency
I'll get more detailed results and if I
decrease it I'll get less detailed
results and it will just show me like an
overall picture so that's kind of how a
sampling profiler works and visual
studio has one built in if we just go to
debug and then performance profiler and
we select CPU usage over here and just
hit start what it will do is it will
launch make sure you're in release mode
for this that will give you much better
results now at the moment we are kind of
running in that not multi-threaded mode
so actually what I want to do before we
do that we can take a look at it now but
it makes more sense to do it in that
kind of multi-threaded version because
it will really highlight exactly what's
wrong so if I go ahead and rebuild that
and now I'll go to debug performance
profiler and start you can also go
relaunch performance profiler so about
27 or so milliseconds I'll let it run
for like a few seconds and then I'll
just hit the close button that will
automatically kind of stop this
diagnostic session and read the
profiling data for us and here we go so
we have the very start of the
application where it just kind of starts
up that's kind of boring what we can
actually do is we can kind of select a
region here that we know is like the
part we want to focus on these are the
samples we're interested in taking a
look at
and then you can see well you can see
immediately where the problem is and we
have like this hot path over here uh but
you can all there's a bunch of different
ways you can investigate this you can go
into for example this kind of open
details over here and then there's a
bunch of different uh ways you can look
at this one of my favorites and what I
think is probably the most useful is
this call tree what you can do here is
you can just press this like expand hot
path a few times and it will just show
you exactly where most of the samples
were recorded So we ran this for
I don't know like five or six seconds or
so you can see we collected 58 000
samples and all this tells us is the
distribution of those samples so we know
that out of like 100 of the samples you
know 52 000 of them 90 of them were
spent inside like this STD run available
chunked work which is almost certainly
part of our kind of for each Loop okay
we'll we kind of expect that per pixel
makes up for 74 of those samples which
again makes sense that's mostly what
we're doing now here is where it gets
interesting random float makes up for 52
percent of the samples so 30 000 of
those samples were recorded inside this
function that means that this function
accounts for 52 percent of our total
kind of usage that is seeming pretty
extreme and if we actually go into here
a little bit further now we can double
click on this at any time and it will
show us the actual code and what's cool
about this is it shows us like exactly
how long kind of each line of codex and
where the samples were recorded uh if we
go back to perp excellent fact we'll see
a bit more detail
you can see that for this entire per
pixel function which which is where we
know all of the math takes place right
that's like what we drew there that is
the per pixel function that will be
called per pixel we can see exactly that
like the complete distribution of how
long stuff takes which is really cool
now again this is a sampling profiler so
sometimes like it would be more
beneficial and more accurate for you to
actually up your samples I think we were
doing it says here 1000 samples per
second you can change that to say 10 000
and you'll get much more detail at the
expense of potentially slowing down the
program a bit but you can actually see
here with varying kind of degrees of red
intensity here where like the slow Parts
kind of are and obviously the
overwhelming slow part in this entire
function is this 53 percent over here
which is Ray Direction equals this kind
of reflect now if you actually follow
this along it's it's kind of this whole
section here because we know that it's
specifically going to be this it's not
the actual reflection and we know this
just by looking at this call stack a
little bit more closely we know that
it's going to be random float now
interestingly there's also this self CPU
so visual studio actually does a pretty
good job at explaining this if you just
hole your mouse over this it says CPU
time spent executing code in this
function
excluding time and functions called by
this function so what that means is
stuff that is actually happening in that
function itself
is not taking up much time at all but it
must call a function that does take up a
lot more time and specifically you can
see it calls this so inside that random
function when we actually do s
distribution s random engine this is
taking up a lot of time so we know that
generating random numbers for some
reason is taking up a lot of time now if
we double click on this to view it in a
little bit more detail all right well my
camera overheated and died so this is
like a week later ah now where were we
um yeah so we're inside the random
number generator and we can see that get
bits is exceptionally hot like 49 28 000
samples inside get bits now if we go
down the rabbit hole a little bit we
need to figure out what exactly get bits
is so get bits is a function I'm inside
like the X utility Header by the way
this may be different depending on what
like platform and compiler you're using
I'm using msvc of course in Visual
Studio on windows so that's why if you
look at the location of this header file
you can see it's inside that msvc
compiler the implementation that you're
using May of course vary so if we scroll
down a little bit we can see the
implementation of get bits over here now
the main thing that it's doing apart
from just like you know trying to find a
value within the range and eventually
returning it is calling this like ref
thing which looks like a function but
actually you can see it's a reference to
U R and G which is a class so this is
actually the kind of call operator on
that class so this is actually calling a
function inside this class and what is
this exactly well it's like the template
argument for this so to see what this
actually is we kind of have to do a
little bit of digging if we go into
walnuts this is becoming like a we
really are going down the rabbit hole we
can see we're using a random engine here
called
mt19937 and if we look at that you can
see it's the messen
Twister engine this is actually the kind
of like pseudo-random number generator
we're actually using if we take a look
at the implementation of that and you
can see it has a base class over here
you'll eventually see that we find this
call Operator over here so this is the
function that's actually being called
from get bits this is supposedly the
slow part and if you don't have much
experience with this kind of thing it
can be a little bit difficult to
actually see what the issue is here
because if you take a look at this
function there's nothing really that
suspicious there I mean we have like
refill upper Henry for lower which does
like what seems like a bunch of math
most of it's behind like an if contact
spur so this stuff gets kind of compiled
out potentially but then all we're kind
of doing here is
seemingly accessing some kind of array
so we have some kind of state that's
actually part of this class and then
we're doing like some exclusive ores
like some bit operations basically
shifting left right you know ending that
kind of stuff now the issue here is that
it is in fact true that most random
number generators have some kind of
state they hold some kind of state and
you can see it really clearly over here
we have an entire array of state whose
index gets incremented the index we
access it at gets incremented every
single time we call this function and
this is obviously very important this
value that we're retrieving from that
state because what we're doing is then
doing a bunch of operations with that
value that we need to retrieve and this
state itself whilst we're not actually
writing to it from within this function
refill upper and refill lower if we
scroll down a little bit you can see we
are in fact writing to that state now
ordinarily that's fine what's wrong with
doing that nothing however this is no
ordinary use case what we're doing is
using this exact State the single
instance of the state across every
single core and thread on our CPU and
what did I say earlier in the video one
of the most common reasons that we'll
have some kind of slow bottleneck here
is because we have some kind of resource
we have some kind of resource here
that's being accessed by many different
accesses like many different threads
essentially are accessing this one
resource and what does that require that
requires some kind of resource
management now in this case there's no
lock on it there's no mutex there's no
like it's not gonna there's no spin lock
it's not gonna wait until it gets access
to it however because we have so many
threads and don't forget this CPU that
I'm using here has eight cores and 16
kind of hyper threads which is part of
something called smt simultaneous
multi-threading we're not going to
discuss like CPU architecture here just
yet but basically if we have like 8 or
16 or whatever cores trying to read and
write from this single array of memory
how do you suppose that that's going to
work well first of all ignoring any
potential errors we might actually
experience from that the real problem
here that's actually causing this slow
performance is because all of the CPU
cache across all of these cores has to
be invalidated whenever we reach for
this variable what would usually happen
if we were accessing this from just one
core is this kind of array would be very
happily sitting inside our CPU cache and
it'd be fast to read it would be fast to
write everything would be wonderful
however since we have so many threads
attacking this memory it has no choice
but to kind of flush that CPU cache and
retrieve the value again now technically
we do have a shared cache between cores
L3 cache is usually shared so it's
probably not quite as bad as like an
entirely cold memory rate from Ram
however the individual cache that lies
inside each CPU core cannot possibly
contain this value because other cores
are also modifying it now this is
actually a really really interesting
topic and to be honest I'm considering
making a video are just talking about
this and writing some code that will
demonstrate more clearly what is
actually happening here but long story
short in this Ray tracing series let's
just cut to the solution how do we fix
this problem well the simplest fix the
easiest thing that we can do is just to
say why on Earth would we have 16
threads or sharing this kind of single
random number generator state if we can
just get each chord that needs to
Generate random numbers to have its own
random number generator state so in
other words if each coil if each thread
was just to have its own instance of
this random number generator engine then
we wouldn't have this issue because the
state is going to be local to that core
the state is going to be inside of CPU
cache and this will be miles faster so
how do we do that in a simple way well
if we go back to like our renderer what
we could do is just say if we know that
we have like I don't know eight threads
we could just create eight versions of
this kind of random engine here if we
had eight instances of that that we kind
of manually created and we assigned one
per core then that would be totally fine
however we're kind of dispatching these
using std4h so there's like even though
we could technically get like the threat
ID and do all of this kind of manual
stuff behind the scenes there's actually
a much simpler way to make this work and
that is all we need to do is if we go to
the random class over here where we
actually declare this we can actually
use a keyword called thread underscore
local and what that will do is basically
create an instance of this per thread
rather than just one kind of global
instance across everything now we also
need to make sure that we go to the uh
definition of that I don't know why the
definition is split up this could have
just been inline static but whatever if
you do have your definition split up
like this then you also have to make
sure that you declare it as thread local
here in the actual definition so with
that one change just adding thread local
to this s random engine let's see the
difference wow look at that
10 milliseconds 10 milliseconds per
frame that's a rather big difference if
I get rid of thread local
just so that we can go back and compare
it quickly that was like 30 milliseconds
so that's a huge difference all because
we now have one instance of this per
thread with the main point here being
that those CPU cores can actually take
advantage of their local cache and there
you go
amazing now there's lots I could
continue talking about here this is a
very deep topic but I want to kind of
wrap this up by just saying this the
main giveaway here that leads right to
this being the problem is the back one I
talked about every single Pixel having
all of this independent math to do it
was really easy to see how
multi-threading would dramatically speed
that up but what we found is that the
calculation for each given pixel was not
in fact as innocent as it seemed in the
sense that it was completely independent
of anything else technically to work out
every actual like closest hit that we
had including like the bounces and
everything when we cast a single Ray so
for each pixel to calculate its color we
would actually need to have that
reflection rate happen which meant that
we needed to generate a random number
and in fact I think three random numbers
if we go back to the renderer quickly
over here inside per pixel when we
actually do this reflect so if we don't
hit anything we obviously break and we
get like the sky color and stuff but if
we do actually hit something we're kind
of in here and you can see we call
Walnut random vect3
which cause float three times which
gives us three random numbers by using
that random number engine and so instead
of our pixels being completely
independent they suddenly now had a link
between them because to get those random
numbers we would have to kind of write
to and read from a kind of shared state
that that single instance of that random
number generator actually had and so
suddenly these weren't completely
independent operations that each core
could actually kind of take charge of
they were now kind of bound by shared
memory that had to be somewhat kind of
sensibly accessed right you had to
invalidate the cache because otherwise
if another core writes to it and you've
got something in your local cache you
wouldn't actually see those changes and
that would be wrong and so by breaking
these links and giving each kind of
pixel its own random number generator
sounds crazy each pixel its own random
number generator but remember it's
because technically that is what's
happening it's not like we're
calculating all like 2 million pixels at
once we're handling those pixels by like
these eight cores so if we give each
caught its own random number generator
that means at any given time when the
pixels are being calculated
simultaneously they are all accessing
their own independent random number
generators and that means that that can
be cached like correctly more
effectively and everything is great now
the last thing I want to say is that I
did actually create this issue in the
ray tracing repository to just ask
people about whether or not there would
be another kind of faster way to
dispatch all the threads we'd need to
actually process like the
multi-threading and a lot of you did
suggest like some certain things however
I believe the consensus is that the 4-H
implementation is actually pretty good
so I am still interested if anyone can
in fact be what we've got right here and
inside this very issue is where a lot of
people did also point out that the
random kind of number generation was the
issue and some thread local random
number generators were also kind of a
good idea which is definitely very
helpful even though the issue was mostly
about the multi-threading side of things
but nonetheless it was nice to see the
community doing some digging and seeing
like what this parts of this code
actually are so thank you hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button as I
mentioned I might make an actual like C
plus plus video discussing like the
intricacies of why exactly this was in
fact so slow and that's why this series
is just such a great way to kind of dive
into C plus and learn about optimization
Ray tracing is just a great candidate
for this kind of stuff don't forget to
check out brilliant using my link in
description below and I will see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
thank you